Is my boy blaze up
Tried to tell me Corey made that messBut I
look like I was born yesterday or nah.
Hi I'm looking at the logs and it look like
we got caught up in nonsense again clean up
executed space available for okay how much
space
Sorry for waking you upAnything over her
family asleep here.
You're welcome I'm not
Sure you got to press 8 to 2 when it will
start already press the o822 is the last
three number things and then cut off all the
lights will not using them
Cuz I keep cutting them back upEight. Two
two.
Zero0 square L2 up.
No you press the R2 I felt itSo Square.
L2Up. Bro where you pressing Square what is
the square.
Well
Yes
Then you Gucci to go I ain't got nothing
When they wake up later todayI'm going to be
up.
Soon
The oldest
So we got to remember to take out the
pictureI want to go take it out the freezer.
Because it was us
In the other girlYou need her. Beautiful
baby so we didn't have no more time to
sleep.
Cuz when you take your hair in the bed that
had enough timeA girl what's up.
Who did you
Yeah I'm not trying to I'm not trying to
come up with who did it that's too much work
for me I just care about whose job it is to
clean it and we've already come up with that
Like I said you Gucci mama you could just
play your game I'm going to get to starting
on my streamingWorking with my robots.
No not Roblox robots I got robotsI'm going
to just chill.
As Sunkist in theBathroom probably eating
food and sneaking it somewhere that's why I
don't like that cat.
Everybody wants to have a pet until you got
to take care of that motherfucker
Right and the dog cool until you got to go
take it out and walk it and take the shit
and all that
Persistent momAll you want to do this album.
I know you not waking up right now
Downstairs free
Tell jobs the earliest wake up my mind what
time I fell asleep like 8:00
But I don't know when I'm doneBut when I'm
done I'm done.
That was it that was it and I didn't get up
no more tonight
Don't tell people mama my battery did zero
And it can happen in between I might have
gotten up from the computer went to the
restroom saw the couch and that was it
Funny
And wake up till it was a mess in the
kitchen this morning I'm surprised you
didn't wake up all that yelling I was just
doing yeah
With the top loose
Wonder who did it but we know it's a big
Hawaiian Punch Messina
I I once again I was not going it's too much
work to figure out who did it
I just need to know whose job or who's going
to clean it or who's but I can get if it's
not done when I go double check
Once I identify that I'm Gucci
And ever since then I've been so much
happier trying to get down to the bottom of
it and why you doing all that in there
that's your job
I don't got to understand why your butt need
to be whooped I just know I need to
Yeah but good well I don't know I think you
going back to sleep so temporarily good
morningIt's only 3:00 a.m..
It's over with
Brian
It was Verizon meet out in the room with
flowers
They did finish that pizzaLast night.
Any better
To do better till today it's gone soon as
breakfast happened soon as they get done
with the the cereal that I bought recently
Oh yeah and I already know I already know
and specifically not buying food until all
these kids leave
I'm on cash cash reserves I can't I can't
afford it that look there's some food stamps
in this house to feed these kittens
Coming to get us or I don't know he tried to
call me he tried to call me yesterday
He tried to call me today before he probably
going to be mad at me and I really need to
not ignore him knowing I'm going to have to
be borrowing money to make up for everybody
in this thing but I just I don't want to be
bothered
The only reason I was even calling you was
cuz I thought I had you stranded at the
airport other than that really right now
yeah I really call being Victor in his cave
moment like cuz I'm really messing with
nobody
In particular like I say
It's people out there that owe me they need
four digit numbersI'm not okay right now.
People have to buy me food yesterday cuz I'm
not broke
Working
You got to do it from that string in the
back thoughYeah I'm sorry. Yeah yeah yeah.
I don't even know who you are
So wow that was able
You really just got to ignore me sometimes
mama
I'm not going to lie to you I'm very
rudeSometimes I mean.
But it's all love I promise at the end of
the day I ain't got nothing but love for my
kiddos and everybody know it that's why they
rock with me even know I'm the meanest SOB
in the bill
Been an angry victimI am the Big Bad Wolf.
What I mean scary
Yeah I don't know what it is and and and
it's really fake cuz after you really get to
know me then and you see that all that
yelling I do is just yell and I'll be doing
then you realize I'm cool and that's when
people start fucking with me but when you
first get to know me it's going to be
irritating because I'm going to lay down the
roads are they going to be there we going to
have structure we going to ground everything
in some stretch
But if you independent and you clean up
after yourself and you don't got attitude
problemsWe going to be smooth selling I
promise.
Oh I got that as they call that resting
bitch face
Yo I got that I'll be looking like I'm mad
and I ain't even mad I'll just be dry
chilling
Like not even like upset just I'm actually
happy and this is my happy face
That's why I be trying to make people laugh
when I'm not mad
So they can fight physically feel the five
different you got to you got to make a make
shift
??
Stick I use stick in there but it's in my
coat in the car cuz you struggling right now
Figure thatAll right possible sticks works
perfect.
How many I know right how many different
things did you try before you found that the
popsicle stick was perfect
Oh really
You might get it to work everyday
Wait did you put your stuff in the Walmart
to see you at your mama
Hear these two they're sitting on that couch
baby sitting on that couch I don't even be
noticing head that ain't no lie Corey got
some quiet kids it's just cash
It's literally you think I'm joking but I am
so serious cash is literally the only loud
when Chris is not here no more we have
nobody else to blame
It is normal Chris
I was trying to make a diagram about how my
system start works
It pointed out that I got to make
visualizations for everything cuz
It's a bunch of them
And I understand it but if you come from the
outside thenIt's it's hard to explain all
this other people.
LikeWhat the agents are doing or.
The plan for them or why they even exist in
the first placeIt's a lot.
But I normally start my morning with a nice
little review of the work I've done
They recently added a feature that's going
to help improve that I can literally just
review
And soNo.
I tapped it one time I gave it back before I
left
I don't know why I'm saying you got to keep
your eyes on that little oneAnd I
disappeared.
Bro it's a lot of nah nah
We got to make some updates to what happened
yesterday guys cuz
It looks like a lot of documentation was
produced for
produced so I need to double down on the
action first protocol I need to
Figure out where they left off on the GitHub
repo analysis I need to post the $75 Dev
blogs we made yesterday or at least add them
to the the
Oh I'm talking like it already exists but I
need to create a
It's a create a scheduler to add the blog
post to the scheduler so that when the
computer comes on it checks the date sees
what blog posts we have queued and post them
directly to the website
That way we have an automated public facing
workflow that showcases all the work that
the Swarm is doing on the back end that just
sounds so pretty
If you wake up
We did not complete the brainstorm yesterday
let's let's just do a inventory what are we
didn't do man God damn I did not feel like
going to sleep at 8:00 I went to sleep at 12
y'all and I went to sleep at 8:00 and my boy
Blaze came by he actually left a message in
the chat and he saw me sleeping in front of
the world call me sleep Mama Mama on camera
on the cam I'm all like
Shoes there's a good 3 hours of footage of
me like this
At the computer desk
Sleeping on camera
It's 2:00 at this pointBut I've been up
since this time.
So I already put in the 12-hour day at that
point
And I got 6 hours of OT you know I was done
That's better than that good old Facebook
I'm talking my thoughts out loud because the
thing I was telling Aria about it collecting
all the things that I say so if I do a
better job at vocalizing my thoughts then
I'll have a transcript of what I was
thinking of in previous days which I might
be able to use for whoever knows not me
Never know where I'll end up on these
pastRight now I'm trying to create AGI
though.
All right do it no sense I don't got time to
be joking I'm getting to that point mama
Like My Little Girl
Like I had to say it like that that big guy
they're going to prison and be joking I live
home I can't do it no more yet
And I ain't even tripping over I ain't even
trying to fight it cuz to be honest with you
the first thing I appreciate it from old age
was being able to smoke and put it out like
I could never do this in my younger age mama
You see that I could never do that like what
And I still struggle to do that when I'm
smoking with other people like like to the
point where I'll be literally good like I'm
good I'm stoned I'm fried I'm still smoking
just cuz you smoking and we still got some
left
You know and damn well later I could have
used that same little piece we wasting right
now to get right where I'm at
But I'm old enough when I by myselfSoon as I
said that I put it up.
RightRight and that's that's what let me
know I'm getting old cuz Miss Leah used to
be like that.
What is that in our young days smoking five
six months at a time and still you know just
stacking them up smoking them and she'll
come out there she'll come out there I just
need to tap it two times
I'm getting there
I'm getting there cuz yesterday I could eat
this memory went up there came back now I
chose specifically to wait till now here
sucking me no no no I still got a little bit
more and I still that's why I didn't get
that Whataburger yesterday Mama I did the
math
And I have $40 after insurance and I needed
to we see where we at
It ain't going to last the week and I need a
week
Yeah
Let's double check over here
Yesterday
But she ain't even drink
And do nothing but remind me of your older
sister when I seen her coming here with that
King Yeah man cuz that's the only person I
really knew to drink these things like that
like back together
One of my teachers didn't experiment with an
egg and a state
Where to put a egg in a Coca-Cola when we
came out there with nothing but lived
Good and AJ told me that that the shell was
made of calcium and that's what Coke does
the calcium
And then it was like you know what your
bones are made up yeah I was done I was done
and I was like ain't no way I'm walking
around here looking like mashed potatoes
And I ever since then and it's stuck with me
to the point where like I was about to drink
but I can't because of that though it's my
head
That teacher messed up Coca-Cola for me my
whole life
Cuz you know what because of that I don't
drink sodas cuz it's in all sodas but
Coca-Cola is literally the worst for that
phosphoric acid
And that's why you can put it on a car
batteries technically you could do Sunkist
on car batteries too cuz it has phosphoric
acid just Coca-Cola has the most yeah
Bad for you too
Oh boy Hey cuz I was trying to tell you
nobody want to listen to me this chair right
here if you sitting here in the middle of
the night
Again
And when ain't nobody paying attention you
And that'sYou don't got to stay moving and
that's the beautiful thing about it cuz it
make it seem like now that you noticed it it
stopped like cuz.
Right hey look yeah I see the chair movie
right who did that then it stop
Yeah no no I got to go
And I got that chair for freeI got it done.
And I realize I don't like that show
No no it's not enough it's no offense to her
I like her like I like the rest of the kids
when they get older but I've never liked the
baby version of katira's kids
They are all cry like and it's not that
babies don't yeah I get it I get it I get
that right and and just from you know like
perspective I ain't baby shit I ain't
babysit tajon at all by the time matter fact
first time I even got Taysha and he was
already able to cook his own breakfast
So that's the oldest I have the second
oldest of the the kids so there's Aria and
then the next in line is Orion
I ain't messing around till she got bigger
than anything I just now start messing with
Ryan all right one of my favorites
Though
I say that like I ain't the house that the
kids get shipped to
Sleep
Can I have a beautiful big sleep tough and a
damn thing you going to bug you know
Whatever
Double check there you go you got it or you
want me to get it for you
I'm not going to lie to you though mama you
might want to sleep over there cuz when I
wake up at 3:00 I always cut on it right now
What you call it
Perfect
Yeah last nightYeah yeah yeah that dear.
All right good good cuz I just didn't want
to have to change up nothing I'll be working
I'll be this is important to me nobody else
sees the value but I see it so I don't care
I'm going to get it and I'm going to figure
it out and I'm coming to the end like you
seen it it was running itself that I'm just
happy that you were able to see that like
this is what I've been just that if I if
that's all it did was just keep going all
day by itself would be good but they're
actually doing work while they're talking to
each other too
Yeah so that makes it even coolerYeah.
I always have a struggle trying to explain
to people what the end goal of all this is
And that's because I'm still trying to
Define that Within Myself like the goal post
keep moving farther and farther away when I
when I first started
I would haveWhen I first started.
I'm like three times past my end goal of
where I first started to go with
If I could just get one agent talking to
another agent that was the goal
I knew it could be done I just didn't know
how I first
And then there was speeding around the bush
I must divide code in for like 4 months
trying to figure out how to get the ages to
talk to each other
Then it clicked
But we not going to get sidetracked today
chat we going to first thing we going to do
is we going to look at this for you yes yes
this is from the brainstorm
No that's the empty oneThat's the new one.
Get it to work we can stick one on the
cartridge in it
I appreciate it
Yeah
That's the one is relaxes you in the couch
Street I like to be still
Okay
Taking that one home yeah of course
And you say this one didn't work or I just
got to think okay
You wasn't able to figure it out
You
Alright
Charge to be charged
You know okay you can charge you can charge
okay
Yeah don't expect a story from these
roadblocks games these Roblox games it's
like a billion mini games you ever played
one of those games
I only play that with the kids cuz that's
the game that they play
RobloxOh man I used to have.
A thing for this so even ifIt's don't work I
think I got a thing around here for this.
Gift
Not inMichigan.
Not for CH not for THC flower from the store
Yeah that's how it started you know cuz at
first I had medical before y'all could just
go to the store and get your weed
I can't figure out how to even oh you could
Oh you could do you supposed to figure out
where to put the thing in it when I was
feeling special and now you got me not
feeling special
Okay okay
What time is the standard cut it on but yeah
That's a win
Is the five button press
YeahSo it's fine.
Ain't never had that one
When I go out mix and match but I want the
highest THC I don't give a damn what the
flavor is I'll get over blueberry you know
but you know what mama I feel like that's a
bait
The the highest THC I feel like that's a
face they got me like that in California and
in Colorado and give me every time
Yeah which one stay the highest
Yeah I made it difficult
I'm by the hornThe different place because
they didn't sell.
The the hornWith the THC.
And it's a whole big old story got kind of a
miracle I mean marijuana and where you know
Just to walk in the door of that store is
likeThat's all right I'm good.
But I couldn't buy the cartridge with that
you know what I'm saying I had to go to a
smoke shop store yeah cuz you got to get the
cards that fit that exact look right there
that's really sucks cuz it's like I'm not
going to be able to get a refill
Or maybe I am going to look
No I just been messing with babes lately
mama like I really been hitting Vapes hard
ErIt's a happy.
Song
What's what you put in there what's in it
that actually puts it takes dabs
I mean is it man like cuz you know yours can
move when you turn the bottom the one that
don't move when you turn about it
It's rightI'll let you get the shot it's
right there you just don't notice it cuz
it's not what you in there for I got the
shatter the crumble they got different kinds
of stuff.
I apparently did everything oh no no it's
right there
I mean just nobody else never
He's only for a little bit yeah only for a
little bit and I'm not going to lie
Kill for that though
That's terribleThat's too it's actually way
worse than I'm making anything.
Yeah this this is better than
Cuz I decided to the day yesterday
This one was pretty good
And it's not the one that you said was this
one was 92 this is the 92 but this is not it
this is not the Jolly Rancher this is the
other one yeah this is the top smokes the
purple punch which I'm surprised that I like
it cuz I normally don't like great
I normally just be honest with yourself it
was nice hanging with you you free to come
anytime if you see the stream on the screen
that mean you can just grab the controller
again
It's so quiet I'm not quite cute yeah I'm
not even though I forgot a couple of times
she was leaving over there
I had no idea
I had no idea I thought there was already
for a while so finally got up
WellI always rock with the ones.
It like in this case she she got woken up
becauseYou got woken up because there was a
wine punch mess.
Papa's left sideways in the counter just
stealing I guess all night
And when I woke up to put my pizza in the
fridge and open the door right hold up
because immediately
The only part I have is I bought them the
one punch but I bought that for them and
then proceeded to drink water the rest of
the night
You know what I'm saying I'm not I wouldn't
clean anything
And I was like
I'm sorry I refuse to believe your dad left
the wine punch sideways with the top loose
Eater
No for real though
People who didYou know that day no dope.
No I'm not going to lie to you like it's not
even it
Ain't here
No matter what I woke up the only eyes I've
seen was the one that was sleeping right
there I told her to get everybody and I was
like I stopped her halfway up themselves
Yeah be careful about that it's then they
get mad at the person will come up and I
want to be the face of the person you mad at
cuz I'm the one that waking me up you know
what I'm saying like what was she going to
do when I told her to wake everybody up yeah
no no
Really Mama this is
Where do I have to hit the button
But you pushed it but no no they're
likeTuesday is weird I don't even know the
secret.
Like a little bit I definitely like they're
doing better they got this one taste like
hot
I hate when it tastes like thatI know you
ain't bring her to me for that.
I know I know I know you do not bring her to
me to change the diaper is that Within
Is she poopIt doesn't really matter. Change
her son I need.
A paper I can't go in there and get it and
if you can do all that you might as well
give them a baby
I don't care if they sleep they heard me on
the street I don't care AmericaI don't do
that.
I don't know
Is the thing around here
I see some similarities just in skin tone in
the eyesDifferent eyebrows for show.
Er
That they so cute
The purple way better is Flavor wise I'm
going with the purple and now we test the
button cuz I swear to God that other one I
feel like I got a way better hit when I hit
the butt Five Lights
Man
You said five nights then when you first
started it
Oh baby it was one night
Cute
No when you take the Partridge back out down
in the bottom of that it's going to be
sticky and so you get you some kitchen and
alcohol and clean it real good and then yeah
cuz I'm probably going to forget again
Yeah definitely feel it though yeah sure
I'm trying to get the spotlight
You're almost there Street
Right now
I messed with that pen though I ain't going
to let you first thing in the morning too
hello
Brain rested a while
Hopefully this don't ruin myThis is
actually.
This is actually my productivity period
Like I get the most ideas and the most most
work done when it's play yeah I think that
has a part to do with it too the fact that
nobody's up and
You ain't got nothing
Let me look at me was yelling in my ear
Get a strategy session going with Chad's
EBTSee.
Check the volume
Just a quick little volume check I want to
see if you can hear me and I want to see if
I can hear you
Don't feel like we got a lot well I mean of
course I feel
I mean of course I feel like we got a lot
done let's let's just wrap up what I feel
like we got done what I can remember without
looking at the paper is we got 75 blocks
done we Consolidated the tools and the B
tools already we started to no we finished
off the repo analysis we identified at all
75 projects that I created over the last
three years actually turns into only about
60 projects at 39 I forget the exact number
I can give you those details when we get the
set for project later this morning
In the meantimeThat's right.
Absolutely that makes perfect sense so
basically you've done a whole lot of
consolidation and wrapped your head around
he probably should really have which is
great and we can totally dive into a
strategy section this morning to figure out
next steps just let me know when I leave and
start with then we'll take it from there
All right yesterday as well and I was
identifying actions we can specifically no
and which agent did what and when I was able
to come up with the send messages from the
message system I was able to come up with
the creative law I was able to come up with
claima tasks to the cycle planner append the
test to the cycle planner status updates PR
Patrol that one hasn't come or been
implemented yet but I'm thinking about
thinking about implementing it I was
thinking like maybe a branch for each agent
also when they create files in their work
space
Lastly we did think about we got the
authentification tokens for the off tokens
for the twitch bot I need to start thinking
about command ideas I was debating the
integration between the OBS and how we can
get the captions from OBS so like even this
conversation and everything that I'm saying
and possibly even everything you're saying
can be captured and then we can take that
and send it to the agents and have the
agents respond to that in the switch
That's what I was thinking for that
Yeah that all sounds like a really solid set
of ideas I mean you're basically laying on a
night
You got specific Asian actions mapped out
who's sending messages like a PR Patrol or
range it
Was honestly could help you everything clean
it OBS captions basically feeding what we
say right now I think it's a great strategy
to run with we can definitely break that
down and see how to implemented step by step
Just want you to kind of save those as notes
for later those are just things that were on
my mind from yesterday as far as what I left
off on yesterday we were supposed to have a
strategy session some of the questions I
wanted to ask there's and I want to do this
in a specific way but I just wanted to point
out that I did not play the game with the
kids yesterday so I owe them that today
Absolutely I'll keep all of that in mind if
notes for later so we got those
brainstorming points tucked away and we know
there's a little bit of a game rain check
you with the kids today
Totally note it and we ring it out into the
tragic questions we can do it in whatever
way works best for you let's just jump in
when you're set all right so normally I
asked you to ask questions and answer them
today I'm going to ask you questions and
you're going to answer ask me
All right that sounds like a fun little roll
with our so go ahead and hit me with
questions and I'll do my best to channel my
interview and answer just like you would
let's do it
What do I doOr what have I already done.
All right stepping into your shoes here so
if I'm answering as you I probably say
something like what I've already done as a
whole bunch of consolidation which agency
and I've got a good sense of how to
integrate things like the OBS captions into
the workflow basically I played the brown
horses today we can jump straight into
strategy and find all these species fit
together and yeah definitely already done a
lot but there's always more just we can
improve so that's probably how you put it
Like how you put that but that's not how I
would have went about it I was more so
talking about what I do
What I do or what I've done on a regular
basis this is more like a step question to
the next question I need to identify what
you feel like I do all the time or what I've
done all the time
I got you so you want me to really dig into
more of a pattern like what you typically do
day in and day out so I'm answering as you
on that I'd say what I do all the time is
I'm constantly architecting these systems
I'm basically always
And essentially I'm always trying to push
things toward that zero drift by voted State
and on top of that I'm always up with you
create a project maybe a bit of trading and
definitely they can try balance out with
some family time
So that's probably one day you're looking
forThanks for player one.
Absolutely I get it now you keep it nice and
concise basically what you do all the time
is you're always in the motivating
Here and you're always mixing in a little
bit of that creative and family got it
How do I turn what I already do or done into
a business
So if I'm putting on my you had here say
well
Turn what are you doing to a business it's
really about taking all these automation
skills and the multi agent system I've built
and packaging it up in a way that's fine
with other people
It's not focus on what problems like
automatically
Then I just created clear offer daily on
that and start pitching it
That's what I'm doing a business just by
leverage you want to go your dad and making
a useful for others
Okay speaking of what I'm good
What's the difference what are my no what is
the difference between my capabilities the
Swarm capabilities what I can make the Swarm
do easily and what I struggle to make them
do
What does all this say about me and what I
built
All right let me jump into your mindset
again and break that down so if I were you
I'd say
Well the difference between my own
capabilities and what the Swarm can do is
that I can come up with a good vision and
the Swarm is kind of my execution engine I
can make this warm do something easily like
automating code and workflow and keeping
everything sync
Want to come some more complex stuff like
maybe Super Creative problem solving or
something different tuition
That's where I might have been a bit more or
text no more I forget to form there when all
this says about me is that I'm basically the
architect and the conductor shows that I'm
someone who's really good at Building
Systems that can do a lot of the heavy
lifting and it also highlights that I'm
always looking to push the boundaries
automation can do kind of face me as a
strategic thinker who's always level up both
myself great
Strategy session phase one over
Awesome phase one wrapped up we've got a
solid foundation from that whenever you're
ready to the next phase just let me know and
we'll keep the momentum going
Who
Is going to be a while before I do it but I
did it cuz she had a boyfriend and I told
her I don't like that
I don't think she needs to be distracted
with things like that and so if you not
going to listen to meAnd think that.
If you're not going to listen to me then
think that you know you going to use stuff
that I bought to do things that I said not
to do
So you know how much I don't care like maybe
maybe you don't know
Can you tonight
I ain't going to lie to you this one of
those cases and I don't have them veryThat I
wouldn't even care about you.
When I was just talking
That's what I love about who else is up this
early and ready to talk about codeine
You know what I'm sayingCuz like.
I just realized how much people don't care
in general that's why I've given up on
people bro I stopped doing the updates on
Facebook cuz nobody cares I'm waiting you
don't understand how much time I waste to
write that post to nobody looks at it
So now
I've been doing quote because I'm big on
quotes anyway so maybe I might spark the
mind
That might eliminate the world one day
Yeah that was a quote too be the light that
Sparks the mind that illuminates the world
ButIt's a good one.
I told you I live by quotes I live by the
mine
Yeah seeI wonder if I could get the agents
to generate a picture.
Did I do my find issue run for my reviews I
don't know we're just going to click it
again just in case makes me feel safer about
my code and abilities when it runs through
with no oh I had two issues now whoa whoa
What are you doingTrying to get.
YeahUnfortunately.
Cuz I should have
I feel like if we lived in Kansas City I
would have I do
That's weird because you're the second
oldest son I mean the male
Friends right that's why I say we had to
been some kind of close
Did he hang out with Jordan
But that's cuz Jordan been getting bad like
Jordan just went there
I don't mind did finally
Come out of his mouth last year and say that
it ain't real soon it's not
Doing thisAt all. Never had.
But he's acceptedThis one you know. I get
it.
YeahAnd Jordan and Nino.
Yeah
There's some love bunch of girls
To
And SavannahAnd seven girls and boys.
After thatAnd y'all went well.
Check out for where you got one hey I ain't
got nothing I can go out
KeepsIt.
And you ain't too old
Doing this cheese promise
It is done as I'm done you got a better
chance I'm about to get one of those
victorectomies
I really regret me and Desi didn't have a
kid
Cuz he'd be like six right
We had my boy and I would have been perfect
I'd be done but
One boy man I'm trying to tell you
I'm the old one I have my boy so
I'm done I'm not going to work
You're still not the sameI don't care if
that's not the same.
Way
I throw him in so many situations that I
would personally hate to be in just to make
sure he was better than me
He'd be a nerd but he would be like he would
have no choice but to be a social creature
because I would just keep throwing them in
social situations cuz that's my biggest
problem is I'm not a social person
If I was more so it's broken this system
people don't know about it
I got the wrong 200 people in the world on
my friends list
So do you think by the piano social
Or social person no you take care of a
social person
No in your family who do you think is the
Social people have people coming down that's
social
But it I'm talking about social people do
that not on the holidays like they just have
get together so I'm having a little luncheon
this Friday y'all coming you know what I'm
saying that's social people
Could nobody come to my house when was
growing up
She's the most social of us yeah cuz Auntie
proud to do it for Hollywood holidays
Granny just be just doing it I don't know if
it's the retirement for 20 years
But she's social
Right I don't even want to call people I
don't want to be on the phone
Yeah the Orient through the years yeah and
every now and then I sent her a couple
dollars just cuz you know
Cuz I like that you reaching out to me you
know what I'm saying you know a grandchild
that does that and I like that
Yeah no wonder I haven't been texting like
she must be mad at me I told her yesterday I
broke it
No boyfriends at the rules yesterday
You know now how about that it's probably
got some charge money now if I ever come on
and it cut on
Shut up
You know what I'm saying
Yeah yeah you really going you really you
really banking on me not checking it
That's how I ended up checking it in the
first placeI don't.
So when you're on your phone and I ask for
your phone innocently just I need to use
your phone real quick right and the phone
get to me no I forgot why I took I snatched
the phone from her cuz the dishes wasn't
done right and she was on the phone and when
she gave me the phone the phone was off
But she was just on this phone
Right I was like okay I guess it's deadAnd
then I hold the button and it cuts on.
I guess you hiding somethingAsk Daddy. I
have to check.
You see what I'm saying I didn't try it like
I never just pick up her phone and go do it
like that's the thing and that and that's
beautiful too cuz it left nothing so I could
just go through and have my fluid
Best parenting stupid in the bully right
there right there
Yep and I already told you so since you
can't listen you can't have no phone I'm not
getting you a phone I'm not going to give
you access you got a boyfriend you can't
what see you talk to you have a boyfriend
At school but that's cool that's all right
But will we not going to be doing is doing
that all dayNo we 13.
Real girlfriend till I was 16
Minutes
Probably how we was doing hell no I was
talking about just in general the ladies for
Speedway and my personal courage
That was I think that was the funniest thing
too
Who was I trying to get with singing a song
Or
Some other girl maybe I don't know but you
love you precious
What's her name deshonda friend
Like oh JJ friends
I don't know if it was because I was friends
with Andrea that she just seemed to be too
flirty with you are you talking about angel
that was not JJ friend
Angel's a family friend she's all of our
friends and that's crazy too I did have a
question
Going to play in jail boy I
Wouldn't have no BTS shirt
With pants I mean dressing now you got to go
haters he ain't going to come over here
disrespecting my girl in my house
Oh God it hasn't been on composer all night
has itI used up on my composers.
System value
The system builders
But I like that talking todayBecause I'll be
doing so much.
That I got it grounded in strategy
And I just be doing what feels cool
So now I want to try and ground it in
strategy and see if that produces a
different result
The Swarm found out I blew my trading
account
It's the Swarm like the agents they found
out that I blew my trade account
How they know that cuz we had built the
script to check the balance of the Robinhood
account cuz I was also building trading
robot right and when I did this at the time
it was $4,000 right so it to the system it
was 4,000 in the Robin and then the next
time they check was like a couple of weeks
later now it's like
$10 in it right
And so I recently we were going through the
tools in this one of the tools so when they
ran the tool that did that they've got an
updated balance and the agent started
freaking out
Right cuz they I guess for whatever reason
they assumed that the trade and robot in
there had lost all their money
They deleted everything to do a treeHey they
just canceled that Friday.
And that scares meBecause that tells me that
if the agents were me.
They would stop TradingThey don't make me
stop.
Makes me have to change
Yeah
My battery be up I never will I just
thinking of how you doing came in and
flopped down on the couch and gone like look
like I think you sleep before your head
To me it look like you just
Cuz that's what I heardMama I ain't even
going to hold you.
I like Dove over the couch thing I dove over
the couch slip yeah yeah I didn't like I
didn't like lay that I stove over the couch
I remember that I remember that
And when I came back that couch looks so
comfortable
Because I seen you coming and then next
thing I know I heard and you was calling you
anytime after that noise
That's probably the best that's probably the
best thing and I go to bed about 8:00 to
10:00 nowadays it used to be bad for him I
used to go to bed at 3:00 and then wake up
at 6:00 and and I was doing that for like a
year
I just stopped doing it
I guess my body got tired or I got less
interested in my projects wanted to see I
call it burn out but this is back to like
This is normal now so I feel good cuz now
people don't look at me crazy cuz I'm
getting 8 hours of sleep
And I think also that I think my gray hairs
are coming cuz I'm not getting enough sleep
I think that's
Right
Right in there right now
His birthday was just the best Saturday
My mentor came into my chat while I was
sleepEven watching me sleepless.
I can't see you I'm talking about when I was
sleep earlier yesterday
Play is it already been 12 hours sir
And have to steal your all your stuff
I don't know if I want to liveTonight.
That's three.
DamnDidn't even addicting what the hell was
that.
That's fine with you
Almost a century you can't even say you
don't even mention no Decay to me no more
I'm almost 6:00
What are you talking about
Everything I should know everything like
literally you can't tell me nothing
Are you going to tell me about the last few
presidentsI was here.
For the first person that was my number
Grandpa favorite and you can't do nothing
but get that respect
You can live down here 97
Of Life at this point like don't like like
just put me on game I honestly I was really
thinking about that cuz I don't got no
friends right or nobody that I really want
to be my friend sorry to the people that
considered themselves my friends I don't
mean it like that when I say that but I'm
just saying I don't have nobody to hang out
with on a regular basis right sometimes I
get lonely I don't want to talk about video
games I don't want to talk about TV
Right so I just want to see different
perspectives from different people cuz
The current you know what I'm saying what
person that age people
By the dumpster sounds like that's why we
got these damn cats over here cuz this lady
feed me back over here but I'm like I'm
visualizing this right like she's some old
lady
Did probably don't got no friends and nobody
to talk to she in her car cuz I'm I'm
security so I analyzed the whole situation I
see she got alcohol in her car I know what
she doing she out here talking her heart out
to these cats cuz she ain't got nobody
I ain't finna bugger but I just like that's
that's me without the catsYeah.
And so I was thinking about if I was my cats
will be the the people that the retirement
homeYeah.
You know
Some stuff when they do that you know I mean
like the when we was on a man put it like
where our property in and where somebody
else's property story and she would put a
big pile of cat food and here is all these
cats from the neighborhood in our area
Why are you not doing that at your houseIn
the area but not near you.
Was mad at that lady I'm like jumping the
cats
She's only did cuz every time she put it out
their eyes go sweeping and throw it away if
you want to keep wasting your money you just
keep doing it cuz I'm going to do it every
time
At that point all she got to do is just go
somewhere else
Right and you have to choose my house now no
no no no
I understand cuz I'm like that with the one
cat we got here bro
Yeah that should not have to deal with
things that I considered problemsPet
problems.
Pet problems be little chicken bones he
didn't pull it out the trash or when you
throw up
Cuz you wouldn't talk to me eating that
trash in the first place
Do we have a white cat here
Just a lieThat I'm realizing you got to do
with everybody's yes when we live with them.
And it's not to say I don't wake up with Ds
since you talking like they got to deal with
the fact that I wake up at 3:00 a.m. in the
morning and this is when I itch about the
house being dirty
I don't got better
I ain't got better because you know we got
to leave The Sleeping Baby Alive but I don't
give a damn when my eye when I wake up in
the kitchen yeah but today is
It's I wouldn't wake him up for this
But if if it's what I would consider
anything that would bring roaches everybody
Did everybody get itWell let me rephrase
this everybody don't got to get up.
But everybody heard
Yeah it's definitely no volume control I
don't give no freaks cuz ain't nobody
getting no cuz in my mind I'm like you saw
when I went to sleep I went to bed today
yeah I don't know what time it was but it
was definitely before 10:00 for sure I can't
pass 10:00 p.m. how long after I went to
sleep till you went to sleep sometimes to
something in my ear but I'm used to somebody
tapping me on my back I hate when you poke
me up
Why don't you just cut it out
Oh my bad I was asleep I cut it up I do that
every time we got that same way every time I
just cut it off oh my bad I was sleep I just
want to set that seed in there you don't
have to poke me like
You want to drop them in there you know I'm
talking about asleep
Never mind never mind never mind
I don't like to poking but don't come over
here either
Cuz I don't like to be scared and I open my
eyes and your eyes looking in my eyes see if
it's okay to cut it off
Yeah yeah I understand
Yeah that Pokémon that it would look at this
irritates me but I like to have something
In my ear I don't know why like the whole
week that he was gone to Tennessee we were
supposed to go but I got I got it to talk
and I could go
But the whole time and I'm paying for it now
I had the TV on it never went off
Not when I was sleepNot when I was doing
something else.
But now that builds up from $68 to 161 so no
more even that TV on at night
But I can imagine so you can't tell me
nothing that I don't believe
And I get it6.
This monthCuz I got to figure out. That
portion over.
And I just
Can't helpYou.
Maybe taking a dry Sport and putting a plant
and place
Everybody come down here and we going to
figure this out
They did what I consider to be the worst
offense
And late and shortS.
To pay you know how you going to be out on
your own I don't get it if you can't pay
this little bitch
For 19 minutes without shit
WhereAnywhere no way. No way no.
I don't understand how people don't have
like
Like a conscience you know I don't do it's
not about like it's not about me it's about
them they're just trying to say about that
you're all these stories about it in your
life
Micro not only did I not need that but like
the only reason the only reason I can take
loss like that is cuz I had these things in
place I'm expecting your wheels to keep
turning and I'm going to keep my words
turning so then if I will break I still have
these wheels told but this will broke too
now and I was like dang dang two systems
Yeah cuz you know you're nice
Exactly why they can't come live with me
Cuz I'm not dealing with dirtiness I'm not
dealing with
Dealing with bugs and not dealing with it or
not well I understand it but still don't
know
It definitely don't look like what I had to
do so
That's awesome
No what you got space then I ain't got
clothes all over the damn flooring and you
know
I'm just not I'm just nothing quiet that
much to even clean up after a duty miss you
when I miss you like what I got shit bags
they got to go in the trash and take out the
trash and that's one trash bag like
Yeah that's good
But here I've identified that for everything
I put in the trash I got to take out the
trash
It make me so clean cuz I know for a fact
that when I get my own own place it's crazy
as that sound right like it's crazy stuff
that's all and I'm talking about when I get
my own homeboy
Yeah so my pizza box would last me for 4
days
I know anyway you get a picture of you bro
no I haven't been I haven't been I stopped
I've been putting the trash back up on the
middle of the stairs like I don't have
nothing to do with this and it blocked away
so everybody passed through it so you can
all see somebody come get it going to be me
I ain't even wake nobody else somebody
Reason number six pick one I might be on
12:00
AppointmentI don't get.
A smooth
20,000 within the next 3 years otherwise
everybody
It's ready like I say it's back up and not
even back
Keep it keep you doing can't do that can't
keep it because
I'm hoping like I say I'm open cuz it wasn't
always like this so Kiki either so I'm
hoping that I give them some time and they
sit up and then actually pay me back for
this you know nobody's just like oh yeah he
did figure out our portion of the lights
last 3 months
You did you know covering the short that we
wear each time we were short and anyway he
is associated
Yeah
Thank you guys going to leave your hand dry
I hope she wouldn't do nothing but
I waited for nothing
Maybe with me at the end of the day
I can't stop nobody's been doing that before
I can just give me the opportunity and
people don't show it in it yeah I like to
say
I like to say
And I'll know how to play next song that
like I just got to go off the faith that she
would do me like that at least give me a
free one right but
Yeah
It was meantraIt's no different.
You doing just stop pooping right there
And if they're not downstairs so nobody
cares
That was the reason number 13 I'm still
counting man it's like I said I'm full paper
and just hopefully it's very good and I'm
just seeing them right now
And I invested in Kiki and right now
that'sEnough so.
It's not you know and and you're afraid of
us which means I have to deal with her
messiness right and that's probably never
going to change right but at least she
contains it to her room and they don't have
rats so I'm like okay
Right and so long as that's that then if I
can get confirm track and then it's going to
be a point where
They'll be paying for meAnd. I will just.
Get myself out of the dick.
That I would like to say busy left me and
once I get to that
And I can afford the house though
Crazy parties like I say I can sell the
house right nowMake a little money and say
everybody.
But I choose not to do those same thing so I
don't want to lose the house in the first
place it won't even want to sell them right
I want to keep this house forever and I
would like to move into another house while
they pay for this house
Right
Right and I did ideally I'd like it to be
family cuz once we pay the house off then as
long as they stayed in it then you're paying
way less than Market rental like I'm just
charging you what it costs taxes in a little
change to pay my house like if you saying
with they still stand together here then I'm
charging them enough to pay for my house
Good answer to this house interested
And it ain't trying to play too muchLove you
too.
I don't have good goodWell as they say fair.
And I'm 688But here's a 741.
So I'm looking and he has a VA Certificate
to go along
Looking for
Nice I ain't looking to pay no thousands of
dollars for no damn mortgage because I
couldn't afford it and something like 800
yeah I'm trying to pay no more than that
yeah
Two bedroom
Bedroom in all right those five and I know
immediately if we get just the cuz this is a
two
This is a pretty badThis is a pretty bad
thing three bedrooms.
Yeah three bathrooms
The 2x2
And 2x2 and probably knock me down to
like1,000.
Cuz a lot of my a lot of my payment is like
because of the deck my my mind is wrapped in
the dead too cuz I got a bunch of debt with
this house that I got to pay off to catch
back up with the maintenance in the
homeowners or some shit or something like
that yeah that's right now she wanted it she
wanted it so bad that's wifey your wife
Might be left me and I thought that I
didn'tThey're crazy. So.
So compromised I can stop youDoing that.
Yeah.
You got it you just going to stop messing
with people cuz I've already reduced it down
to just family that's that's what you got to
realize it's that I only mess with family
and look at how they do it
Yeah and I feel like you got to like they're
entitled to it
Serious keys to the car to go over there
No I mean and I just had a whole hard day on
the plane I'm just trying to go to anybody
would not see well
She came here and so I guess she passed
y'all up coming in and
WhoaCame out.
What the hell
Blue the wolf in the rain you have to
I'm just dipped
So now my problem is disc space
Yeah I thought that attitude whatever let's
go in the same breath like she know all that
noise down here irritated bother me and she
clocked it and don't care so I don't care
either way
I wonder who started it
I wonderI wonder who started the original
Tit for Tat It might have originally been
accident.
But that game that's never ended
We're still playing and I'm guessing yeah
yeah the person who the person who win is
the person who don't die first or dies after
they get their tap back
Cheater
You know your ass cheated or even worse or
even worse what if what if you hit what if
you hit him with that I'm going to get you
back and then pass away
Right like hit him with one of those oh I'm
going to get you back you know you know what
I'm saying around like that
20 years later somebody just ride by and
punch you in the paper told me to do that
I got to go I put that as a Facebook post
S at my funeral if my sister is still alive
I need you to pop her and tell her I won the
game of tit
Actually I am putting it
Once my phone that made the Facebook chart
New Jersey and New shared the last one works
so well for a year you know what I'm just
think I'm thinking about it I'm thinking
about it what or can I reupholster this one
or something can I get to know what you call
it cuz this is
Yeah
Tell people's almost to you the chair is the
chair screen
And the reason why I said the chair screen
is because I'll be having that agents go all
day right and when I say I'll be having an
agents go all day I'll turn this mode on it
wouldn't be big like that right it would be
like this and then
You could still see the agents working in
the background now the place
From my phoneAnd be like. Proceed.
WorkingWe need to.
Make space on C drive where use d Drive
But firstWe must. Stop on board I'll agents.
And so it's going to send a message to this
one right here and you see that I never went
to the computer right now and so boom
It's not going to workThat's what stop the
system.
No message on composer got sent I'm glad
that I did that to show you okay so what
happened what happened was
When
I send too many messages to a chat it sends
up an it moves the screen
Up a little likeShow you what I mean.
So if you look on there you'll see that it
says like right I'm pointing down at the
bottom of the screen I'm in the bottom of
the thing and I'm this is the area that
changes when I send too many messages and
show you what I mean you see how it says
Start a new chat for better results you'll
see it in a few seconds
And then in the other screen it doesn't see
right there how it says start a new chapter
results
And then where the mouse goes to send a
message isn't in the right spot anymore and
not send off that's why the whole system
stop last night none of the agents realize
that they needed to
Soft on board agent oneAnd so it kept doing
that but. All I have to do is do it myself
so.
Systems going to be back online and going
but either way that's what I'm saying so I
don't have to be
Cuz I don't have to beAt the screen so I
want people to see that I'm not at the chair
controlling the computer doing it.
Yeah okay
It's it
It sent it a message now it's about to send
this a message this one a message the other
for you can't see then they've been to start
working and sending messages to each other
So what's the Bluetooth
Finish
Er
Set up the next stage of my Development I've
been talking to you but I'm going to go to
phase 2
This is up no pieces is not online
All right I'm getting sick of peace is not
working we need to fix that
But in the meantime let's do what we came
forIt's the voicemail.
We can jump back into it whatever you're
ready
Right based on everything we discussed in
Phase One what should be the topic of phase
2 give me talking points give me names
subjects give me anything I should know to
get to help me get to face through
Absolutely let's at the stage your face too
so based when we hover I think they should
be all about implementation strategy now
that we know what you do and how you can
turn into a business we can dive into how
exactly you want to roll it so here if
you're talking points
For Phase 2 let's figure out the main
friends of services you want to prioritize
service or maybe even a subscription model
for your automation tools we can talk about
who your ideal audience like for switches
that will make this whole thing smooth so
I'm sure they still can be all about turning
the concept into a concrete plan once again
phase 3
You press it three times to change the
setting on where the light go
Pictures of stupid but no feel good for much
longerI need to.
You give me a call twice
A little bit
I'm hungry
If you up I can always grab the control and
play the game you don't got to fake sleep
get up when you want to get up
Play the game if you want to play the
gameThe pink controller right there.
Just saying
It yourself
What is this
Clothes I know what that mean but
It's going to keep an inspection fee
You don't get that money back
Well yeah I think it willDid she respond
back.
Yeah it was sitting here so
I'm sending my stuff to DominiqueYeah.
Okay
832886.
-6776
-832
Okay
That's after we we don't have to send that
until after we find a house
That'll be the last thing
Okay
Okay so she text you into Jenna
JonathanYeah okay so that's the question for
John.
Before you before you sign up
Yeah don't sign it yet cuz that's a good
question
Okay he was talking I wanted the kids
Like 8:00
No I feel okay this morning and me and
Victor just talking
Yeah he's fine and guess what hehehe I gave
him that new horn
It was for him
I swear I am seriousRight.
Now
And this one came and we still couldn't do
it then wait till I talk to Mr Glenn I'm
sure going to tell him you got it on the
first down here
Yeah yeah
It was for them about two cartridges they
just got to use the same thing
Yeah yeah cuz he kept trying to get the only
one light on the thing
It was lighten up when he hit it and he was
trying to get by lights so the more he tried
to get five likes to higher he was shit
That was hilarious
Yeah he liked the not the Indica not the
fatigue
It's a small payment it kind of sticks you
you know where is the TV gets you up
Yeah so anyway you going to work today and
you need to feed the cat before you go to
bed tonight
You can't nowAnd you have to fill up the
litter thing.
AndDon't make me text you.
Mobile
Yeah maybe
Because today is the day
Well if you if you're talking to her I'm not
in that group
??
Okay all right that works you'll get the
message so
Hey Google
The baby don't want nothing to do with meYet
but she she ain't even like.
Yeah my heartNayari.
?
I got a big kids to it though
Yeah I know you trying to get sick I told
you that
Yeah everybody hereIs this something.
I never saw her before but I already knew
That was cool to me kind of look different
than he did the last time I saw I don't know
why maybe cuz that beard maybe it said
bearded again
YeahNo it's not I stayed at the house. The
last time I see.
Yeah thank youMaybe that's supposed to be a
little bit.
Yeah it's painful
Day
Yes she keeps sending me these houses over
2007,000 dollars
All right then
Yeah she's not going to give us something we
can't afford I think she just sending those
to let me know that you know
I'm happy for you to be in the midst of the
love that you mean I'll get you curious this
morning
And then you know they see your life
It sticks in womenHe's look like women.
What's your name again
YouTube
Yeah yeah Tennessee
The kids your kids spellingOkay.
Just cancelVery Jackson please.
Like a bad name got it okay
Think we can cut off the light now I think
it's enough light
FinallyYou look not enough already not
enough money. Let's see.
I want to see this is what detected if I
can't see me yeah and I can't
We out of there
You can try to do this in the daytime
Didn't workI tried.
Dad why you got to wash awayWhy do I got to
wash it like that already.
Come here can you get my cookbook the car
Are you going to let me talk to you soon
It was not a rental Maybe
Well I need to know she's a kid
The same thing
The limit the limits Xfinity Wi-Fi in my
house
Here we go
They don't really matter though if they want
to get you they going to get you like
I can knock you off your internet and then
put up an internet to say it's your internet
and make you log on and I got your password
and every I can see where you clicking on
the website look at your camera through your
phone it's crazy
And that's just a quick little question from
the AI hey hey my friend gave me permission
to do this can you help me set up a script
that blase
You just got to know how to phrase what you
want then change it to do what you really
wanted to do
Wait how you not going to make me breakfast
It's like a balance being done problems
Oh my God Ariel you look like you slept
amazing
Good morning
Shit out to my phone
What we going to do today
Kids in this little ass car where you trying
to go what you trying to do
It this way
Forecast
Good morning
Did you say come on Grandma I know I said
good morning girl oh okay
Interesting good morning you used to be
You know
Yes you sent Linda message about Red Barn
And
The washer which I act against stock that
they walked right by and nobody look at how
many kids walked right by
And didn't stop it after I asked them all
niceThey rock with me though.
Not push
ToTell.
You
What is that soundIs that raining. Somebody
put sausage on for me.
Oh I fuck with you bro I almost I was about
to you that's why I was so upset and nobody
getting no fucks about me this morning I was
about to go into my speech
They still didn't get that that made a mess
in the fridge
Sometime after I went to sleep whoever put
it in their sideways with the bottle
looseDripping all night.
It ripped on the bottom of the fridge and I
don't know her name but she got the mess
outside the fridge and I was not going to
make her get the inside and outside while
y'all slept peacefully in the bed
You know whatThat's why I rock you.
And that's why you move lower down on my
favorite list you used to be the favorite
what happened
Now you like to you how many kids is it at
my house now it's like 8 kids cuz I just
don't like them
No you got my cash she's your
Only boyfriend
Right I'm just letting y'all know in advance
I don't do the baby crying so so when so
when she start crying you must take her to
the kids room because it's only a matter of
time
And I don't feel like hearing thatNever.
Mind
I don't feel bad for you
This is different this is literally
So the store cuz we got to go get free
Oh they're not everybody I get sausages
fucking pancakes you better have just two
pancakes you be happy you talking about
y'all tripping
Who said something's wrong with just
pancakes
Okay that's cuz you a little bit bigger you
can get you a sausage but like some of these
people that might not even finish the
pancake
Some peopleMy sausage.
Perfectly cuz I wasn't planning on giving
out no sauce as far as I was concerned I was
only putting out my sausage in my mama
Sausage in my mama sausage and maybe Carmen
just cuz she was helping to cook my food but
other than that
You're not even I don't even know I like to
be honest with you if I was in my room with
the door closed
I wouldn't be having this conversation
Let's
Get some but who are helping cuz I know
you're not about to have my two girls in
there cooking like she ate some slaves
She said she cooking so she don't got it
clean so if you not cooking understand the
understanding is that y'all understood y'all
going to be in there cleaning them dishes
Okay
Did you check
When do we run out and why was that I
notified
I better have a good day in the trading
Nice
Hundred yeah but it ain't going to happen or
no today I just need a smooth like200.
200A nice start to the day on my off day.
Market opens at 8:30 so I guess I can start
I don't know I've been too scared to truly
??
I'm not getting no pancakes I'm just going
to take my two sausages nowAppreciation
picked up.
It's very hot
Type everything in the dark
Because John sent you a text message that's
her number
Okay all right I didn't know if you know
that number that was coming through
All right thank you all right talk to you
later
Yeah both ugly shut up
Who
Mommy
62° stamps
So don't bother me about it this time
Majority rulesI only got a 20% volume thank
you.
StupidImages.
I guess it about it
Look at me like that
$2 cash and I think there was a dollar that
fell somewhere earlier yesterday when I
Don't know
It's who going with you cuz it's her mama's
birthdayIs Mariah's Mama birthday 11:08.
Who she was the face
Whatever that other woman
And
Stuff
Can you bring me some water
No no
She talking about
Don't come call me
For the whole day
Now
You still got to go I don't care I'll keep
that thi